we have a lot of things in common so
Alejandro and yet to route picking up
three Oscars and I thought that the
movie was magnificent actually we and we
need actually the type of movies you
know that I'm not basing with all my due
respect not doing special effects and
stuff like that but a movie about
relationship a movie that is risky he is
stepping a very very complex territory
so for the Academy to recognize a job
like that it's important I think they
were bedding I think the Academy this
year therefore for movies that actually
you know go beyond the parameters of
what is normal
what do you think it was about
Alejandro's directing that was so
special because a lot of people were
commenting on the way it was all as if
it was shocking one tape was very very
impressive it was impressive the whole
entire thing the reflection of his name
the universe the rollercoaster of actors
you know is a movie of acting inside the
movie so and you know for us
specifically it's very true I have being
in Broadway anybody finally because I
went to Broadway right after that is
over and the story is a guy who wants to
Broadway after he did like mile or per
mile right and so I know the period of
rehearsals for me was back racing so
when I saw the movie in a way I felt a
little identify with that but I think
any actor would identify and you know if
you go a little bit beyond that any
person that has moment of crisis and
it's very well described in the movie I
think all of them Michael
yet when Norton everybody in the movies
fantastic they seem to comment on
Hollywood as well and actors I mean they
were taking the met quite a lot wasn't
it absolutely but you have to know when
you get in this you have to travel with
that backpack of success and Fiasco
that's not only the life of an actor
that's life in general
have a wonderful evening thank you so
much thank you